this video has been sponsored by hong
kong impact third if your family was
killed by horrifying goblins what would
you do they took everything from you and
now they're about to destroy everything
you love again unless you stop them i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to be to the
goblins in goblin slayer this priestess
girl signs up to become a new adventurer
right as she meets this group of young
explorers who are also looking for
another member to add to their party and
this guy tells priestess girl that
they're about to go on a hunt for
goblins who've kidnapped some girls from
the town only one tiny problem they're
all porcelain ranked which is the lowest
rank that an adventurer can be and this
reception girl knows they're about to
get slaughtered but the ever eager
priestess girl accepts their invitation
and the hunt begins the gang enters this
eerie cave and priestess girl begins to
get too scared for her own good and this
guy reassures her that goblins are
nothing to be afraid of and he knocks
his sword on the roof of the cave and
our priestess girl even finds out that
this gang lacked the money to buy any
extra equipment before they agreed to go
on this quest meaning they're going on a
hunt without any extra gear right as she
hears and sees a horde of terrifying
goblins jump out from behind them oh
these guys failed so spectacularly it's
disgusting and it was obvious from the
get-go that they came into this with
their hopes and dreams leading them
rather than practicality and this will
get them killed the problem is this that
in spite of their notorious reputation
most people think of goblins as
insignificant pests that can be easily
dealt with but this couldn't be further
from the truth but let's say we take the
goblins out of the equation completely
this group started off on the wrong foot
it was beyond apparent once that dude
bumped his sword on the ceiling of that
cave entrance and that was no
coincidence the weapon he appears to be
using is a long sword and was
characterized as having a cruciform hilt
with a grip for two-handed use and it
was characterized not so much by the
longer blade but by the longer grip and
it was more prominently used as a weapon
for mounted or fully armored knights as
in people fully suited up meant to be
fighting in wide open fields this idiot
i mean kid he failed his group he did
not take into account his surroundings
his group is going into a cave where the
tunnels are not always going to be big
enough for him to use a two-handed
weapon the chances of him not being able
to use his full skill set with a
two-handed weapon go way up the chances
of his sword getting stuck go way up
this kid is an idiot he should have
picked a much shorter sword they failed
to plan for this goblin quest they did
not get to know their enemy to the point
where they clearly knew that going too
far deep into the caves where the
goblins have home field advantage is a
bad idea they should have stayed closer
to the surface near the entrance and
lure the goblins out one by one they
should have used other means such as
smoking them out because the goblins
have the nasty habit of attacking in
great numbers and it's going to cost
them big the terrifying goblins start
attacking the gang in a frenzy right as
this wizard chick starts blasting spells
only to get overrun by the goblins and
stabbed good and this dude is even more
useless than we thought taking pot shots
until he fumbles his sword and gets
brutally killed with this other chick
faring even worse and gets preyed upon
by a goblin it's a horrifying sight and
all hope is lost when suddenly priestess
girl and the goblins hear incoming
footsteps of something or someone
revealing himself to be the silver
ranked adventurer goblin slayer himself
and he orders priest girl to use her
holy light before he messes everyone up
killing goblins more efficiently than a
suit torn peter parker burning this cave
and killing the shaman goblin leader
himself eventually saving this one
adventurer girl and even killing the
baby goblins of this horrifying nest
showing us just how merciless this guy
really is goblin slayer then even
mentions that goblins should never be
underestimated especially ones being led
by a shaman like this guy or by a goblin
lord the next day priestess girl meets
goblin slayer again at the town center
and they get their next quest involving
goblins of course and might as well as
countless adventurers disregard goblins
thinking them to be nothing more but a
pest problem a quest only meant for
beginners and amateurs later on goblin
slayer and priestess girl reached the
next goblin nest a sinister looking
ingrown tree trunk housing goblins
within and priestesco readies some fire
arrows for her silver ranked superior
and he fires them with everything he's
got causing a massive fire to surge from
within the goblin base and he suddenly
orders priestess girl to cast a spell to
trap all the goblins inside the nest
burning them alive this shocks priestess
girl who sees how automatic and
emotionless goblin slayer is to all of
this telling her to keep her guard in
case any of these goblins manage to
escape somehow no goblin is to remain
alive okay this priestess girl needs to
stop feeling sorry for nature's worst
mistake goblins like to dwell on
frontier lands untouched by military
forces and they have the tendency to
prey on small villages and raise terror
on folks that cannot defend themselves
and because the goblin species is an
entirely male group tell me how do you
think they get down to the business of
being able to reproduce
that's right which is why some of the
greatest crimes from goblins can range
from serial mass breedings with the
females of other species to mass murder
even leaving a single child goblin alive
can come back to bite you because these
vindictive little bastards like to hold
grudges and can rapidly grow into adult
states which can make them into an enemy
that you would never want to mess with
the thing that makes this breed so
treacherous is that they always hunt in
mass numbers despite their inability to
be super smart they aren't dumb asses
either and will eventually learn
whatever it is that you throw at them
which is why maintaining a distance and
striking first and heart with no mercy
is the best strategy that this group
could have planned for what i would
worry about in the future would be in
regards to priestess girl and her
ability to maintain a high level of
endurance when it comes to casting and
retaining the presence of spells by
sheer will because from the looks of
things here it seems as though she
hesitated when ordered by goblin slayer
to cast that spell and it's obvious that
she lacks practical experience i would
worry about how she'll handle things
next time her adrenaline spikes and were
in critical danger i would make her
practice all her spells in her arsenal
till she pukes the moment we got back to
the village because while we might be
with the goblin expert their ability to
overwhelm us by sheer numbers cannot be
ignored which means the next time we're
out priestess girl must not choke under
the pressure but you know it won't cost
them their lives while out on the hunt
hong kai impact third this time bringing
to you the latest and greatest 5.5
version to the captains which already
started by the way back on february 24th
introducing chicks all strongest
valkyrie bianca ate gina however this
time around they've got some new
characters starting with doran doll the
first valkyrie to have black and white
forms which is so cool and with a deeper
secret meaning behind her special
costume which you can find out within
the game specially designed for this
cruel beauty during doll the battle suit
plantainous equinox with two alternate
forms knight and guardian and for her
graceful companion rita you'll be
awarded the spina astra battle suit
hongkai impact has also prepared four
new outfits for two valkyries meaning if
you get one outfit you can open up the
other one automatically and to top it
off during doll and bronya are also
getting a new cheap pal the heavenward
dragon and the heart of the night
respectively and remember when you
obtain the heavenward dragon or the
heart of the night you'll simultaneously
obtain the glasses on version
celebrating the anniversary of the
global server joining in will reward you
with a fourth anniversary emblem along
with a trove of upgrade materials and a
very large sum of cards and over 4 000
crystals and releasing on february 26 is
their very own hong kai carnival which
is a one-hour special live event
download the game now to redeem the gift
code in the description down below and
thank you honkai impact third for
sponsoring this video the dawn of a new
day arrives and in comes a party of
three featuring this elf girl who we'll
call legolas chick or orlando bloom for
short i'm kidding legolas chick then
tells the receptionist that she's
looking for a famous adventurer named
orc bulk the receptionist has no idea
what the hell she's talking about and
neither does she know what dwarf guy
over here is talking about either just
then lizard guy mentions that they're
looking for the one known as goblin
slayer right as he appears from behind
them they then tell him that they have a
new mission request for the man himself
in this conference room they mention
that due to a growing number of demons
in the capital thanks to the
resurrection of a famous demon king a
horrifying battle will soon take place
between them and the rest of the world
but while the elves and the rest of the
world's species prepare for this great
battle an increasing number of goblins
have started becoming more and more
active everywhere making the
preparations for this battle against the
demons impossible however this group of
adventurers have found one active
goblin's nest responsible for all of
this which is why they need someone who
knows goblins and so goblin slayer
accepts the job not knowing that this
time around it'll cost him everything he
has including the lives of his pals if
he's not careful enough later on in the
night the adventurers share a meal with
each other and begin familiarizing
themselves with one another all of their
strengths and weaknesses okay hold up we
need to talk about the additional
members of our party because unlike the
first goblin hunting group that we met
that got obliterated by goblins this
time around we seem to have some real
potential within this group lizard guy
is a cleric which means he can use magic
along with conventional weaponry and can
cast up to four spells a day with the
spells ranging from summoning warriors
from the undead to making weapons appear
out of thin air performing healing
spells using magic to increase his own
strength and possesses the ability to
rust any equipment rapidly and can even
produce the sound of a dragon's mighty
roar but the thing about this character
is that we finally have a powerful
partner that can aid us in performing
brute force attacks in the form of
getting up close to goblins and unlike
priestess girl this guy doesn't need to
rely on his magic in order to kick some
serious ass legolas chick is another
serious addition to our squad because
she's an elf she's over 2 000 years old
and she knows how to use a bow and arrow
which means we now have the ability of
ranged attacks against the goblins
because unlike a goblin slayer's ranged
attacks this elf has the ability to fire
arrows in curved paths she can change
the trajectory of her arrows and she can
fire multiple arrows simultaneously
with extreme proficiency now dwarf guy
is a shaman which means he can also aid
us in casting spells up to four a day
those abilities do require a catalyst in
order to function such as casting wine
into the air in a fine mist enough to
cause anyone who breathes it in to
become incredibly drunk and
non-functioning and because of this he
also has a bag of spells up his sleeve
this group provides us with a range of
possibilities with how we'll be able to
tackle the goblins from relying on
priestess girl to provide us with
healing and shielding cover to using
lizard guy as backup if we need to
defeat the goblins quickly and with
brute force along with using legolas
chick to provide us with tactical ranged
cover thanks to her ability to control
the trajectory of her arrows and help
even dwarf guy with his clumsy spell
casting will still prove to be useful
since we can use his odd spells as
method of distractions against the
goblins in case we ever need to surprise
them from behind needless to say we've
got some talent this time in this goblin
hunting roster the burgeoning blossom of
a new day begins and the sun ascends
over this goblin nest entrance just as
these vicious monsters get shot down by
legolas chick emptying the area of the
monsters and the group of adventurers
prepare to enter what might as well be
goblin hell itself slowly but surely the
group combs through the corridors of the
sinister looking catacomb catacomb-like
structures right before legolas chicks
spots a trap right in front of the group
but goblin slayer notes that this is
strange since unlike before there are no
totems in sight meaning there's no
shaman around and ordinary goblins would
never be able to set traps this means
there's something much more sinister
leading the goblins down here little do
they realize just how right they are
dwarf guy then recognizes the tracks as
the group prepares to take down the
horrors that await them and they enter
an atrium-like room holding dozens of
sleeping goblins but this goblin slayer
is one crafty son of a gun and prepares
the group with his plan of attack
starting with dwarf guy and priestess
girl combining their spells to create a
sleeping spell more powerful than even
two downed bottles of tequila allowing
the gang to put these goblins to sleep
for good however suddenly the gang feels
a blasting wind erupt from a dark
entrance way forcing the group to take
notice of the impending bellowing
footsteps approaching them fast it's
something big and something far more
powerful and bigger than any goblin
anyone has ever slayed before it's an
ogre okay this group is royally screwed
aside from his massive structure and
brute strength this guy can regenerate
minor wounds inflicted upon him by
swords and other sharp weapons and has
the ability to cast a massive fireball
and this means that one spell casted
from him and were dead which means we
need to take out his ranged attack first
and foremost or more specifically the
method by which he summons his spell i.e
his mouth if i'm goblin slayer i need to
use the entirety of my group's strengths
in order to pull this off option one the
entire group attacks and distracts the
ogre while legolas chick fires fire
arrows into the eyes and mouth of the
ogre ideally blinding him and severely
burning the inside of his mouth and
esophagus i would then have the group
retreat and utilize ranged attacks
before going into close quarter combat
to take the ogre down option two i would
have dwarf guy summon a fierce spell
which is a spell used to control a
goblin's emotions however in this
instance i would order him to use this
spell to call out a swarm of locusts to
distract the ogre as he has done this
before with this spell in the past this
in of itself won't stop the ogre but it
would buy us enough time to not get
wrecked by the ogre's fireball time in
which i would order priestess girl to
use her spell of purification which is a
spell to remove the impurities from
people and items this when performed on
a living being could in theory turn
their blood into water and i'm pretty
darn sure that an ogre's blood is not
that clean which would in turn kill the
ogre now this last part is highly risky
which is why beforehand i would have
priestess girl try out as many different
ways that she can utilize her spells
because if she screws up on this plan
then we're all dead if i was goblin
slayer a contingency plan that i would
have in case priestess girl didn't have
the balls or the skills to be able to go
through it would be to make use of
lizard guy's partial dragon spell which
would enhance his strength and speed
greatly and i would have goblin slayer
personally down a bottle of stamina
potion which the group does carry i
would then utilize both his and lizard
guy's attacks to come at the ogre in an
omnidirectional fashion and simply cut
him down where he stands since we'd both
be effectively on magical steroids all
the while having synchronized attacks
from the rest of the group this
horrifying ogre isn't playing games and
creates this giant pulsating fireball
right at the same time priestess girl
conjures up a magic wall protecting the
gang but the spell from the ogre
exhausts priestess girl fast allowing
him to land a blow to goblin slayer's
face in an instant knocking him down
hard forcing priestess girl to tend to
his aid granting him the quick strength
to whip out one of his scrolls right
before this ogre prepares to obliterate
him with another fireball until suddenly
goblin slayer cuts him down with a
magical gate scroll linked to the bottom
of the sea unleashing the menacing
pressure of the deepest parts of the
ocean causing the water to unleash at a
terrifying speed and tears this ogre
apart taking out one more ungodly
creature from this earth later on
elsewhere deep beneath the town sewers
these two rookie adventurers try
fighting these ginormous terrifying rats
but this dude gets his sword stuck
within the corpse of one of the rats and
this other wizard girl isn't of much
help forcing them to abandon the quest
entirely which means no pay and they've
just lost their own weapons and so flat
broke they end up sulking all the way
back to the town's center and decide to
ask an expert for their help on how to
slay the menacing overgrown rats hiding
beneath the sewers so they decide to ask
goblin slayer himself who tells them to
use a club as they're easier to find for
free and so now loaded up on weaponry
the duo heads back down into the depths
of the town's sewage system and run
right back into these unstoppable rats
however this time beating these things
isn't the main concern as they just have
run into an army of disgusting
godzilla-like cockroaches forcing them
to run for their sweet lives
okay this is the absolute stankiest
situation i would never want to be in
and worst of all we've just crossed
paths with nature's nastiest little
villain the cockroach though at the very
least in our world we don't have to go
up against those steroid-abusing
cockroaches from terraformers which
means we still have a chance now we
don't know what year this takes place at
but it's clear from the decor that we're
definitely back in medieval times and if
that's the case in those days let's just
say the world hasn't worked out the
cleanest way to treat their sewage waste
with some parts of sewage tunnels back
then even containing enough methane and
chlorine from buildup of waste to be
highly flammable and incredibly toxic
though from the looks of that lit candle
it makes me think that the concentration
level of gas present down in those
tunnels is not high enough yet at least
for us to use to our advantage and those
stupid kids of course came down into
this hell hole completely unprepared
which means i think we've got only one
more move in our pockets this girl is an
apprentice cleric which means she's kind
of like priestess girl but way less cool
and as a result she's only got one spell
a bolt of lightning that she can use but
the thing is she's just a rookie which
means i wouldn't trust her with a ranged
attack if that attacker was two feet
away from her and so because of this we
really only have one option which would
be to make her shoot a massive boat of
lightning up towards the roof of that
sewage system causing the entire thing
to collapse separating us from those
things completely now i know it's a
gamble but it's safe to say that the
sewage system isn't up to code as ones
in the modern day and well we really
don't have many other options here so
it's time to take some risks using a
combined method of throwing the lit
lantern and using wizardry the duo burn
and stun the cockroaches enough to knock
them on their backs before slaughtering
them unknowingly preparing them for an
upcoming battle that will test
everything they have along with goblin
slayer soon enough back at the town's
center goblin slayer finds a request
from someone from a far distant land
that specifically asked for him someone
none other than the archbishop of the
supreme god the sword maiden herself a
legendary gold ranked adventurer who 10
years ago defeated the demon lord
herself so goblin slayer along with his
gang sets out for watertown an idyllic
town with a much more sinister problem
dwelling beneath the city's surface and
to top off the bad news legolas chick
and priestess girl make goblin slayer
promise to not use any water torture nor
fire nor poison against their soon-to-be
goblin victims just as the gang reaches
the town and more specifically the
temple of law itself where sword manen
tells the group of adventurers that
about a month ago an assistant of the
temple was brutally murdered late at
night while out on an errand with her
corpse sliced right open while she was
still alive and that attacks on women
and abductions on children have begun to
increase ever since then the sword
maiden then tells them that they've
discovered the culprit behind all of
this not a man but a goblin and since
this town was built upon another town
there's no doubt that where they're
hiding is beneath the town's surface
deep underground and because of the
demons raiding the capital the military
spread too thin to help which means it's
up to goblin slayer and crew to take
them out supplied with an old map from
sword maiden the gang plunges deep
beneath the earth's surface and sure
enough encounter a horde of terrifying
goblins right from the get-go and
quickly cut them up just like a bad boy
chef at benihana but something is up as
there's just too many goblins to handle
with this boat charging down the sewer
nile full of flesh-hungry goblins coming
right for this group's throat forcing
the gang to work together priestess girl
then uses her spell as a shield just as
goblin slayer throws a blinding smoke
bomb right before him and lizard guy
rain hell upon these green goblins dwarf
guy here then drops a giant rock on top
of the boat sinking the ship along with
the goblins all the way down to the
bottom but they're not out of the woods
yet because just then this horrifying
reptilian beast pops out of the water
and surprises the hell out of the group
forcing everybody to run okay we are in
serious trouble here because this swamp
dragon doesn't look like it's a vegan
now realistically this swamp dragon is
no different than a plain old alligator
which is why we could use what we know
about these sneaky swamp dwellers to our
advantage because face to face we can't
really think about taking him head on as
its overwhelming structure would likely
be too much for us to handle in the
moment however the one thing that we can
take on is its head literally because
the snout of an alligator is covered in
sensitive receptors to make it snout and
obviously eyes the most vulnerable
points on its body and this is where our
little dwarf friend can finally pull his
weight because he's exactly who we need
for this scenario unfortunately though
casting spells takes a few seconds which
means we'll need to give dwarf guy some
time enough in which he'll be able to
cast his spell which is why i would
order lizard guy to throw dwarf guy
ahead of us as we run like an american
football which will clear dwarf guy of
the monster and give him at least 4-5
seconds of time before we catch up to
him again giving him enough time within
that time frame to conjure up a stone
blast spell creating some rocks and
making them grow as big as hell before
firing them in rapid succession towards
the alligator's snout and eyes
distracting him enough to wean him off
of us completely or give us enough time
to get away from him within that hallway
because we don't need to defeat him we
just need to get him off of our tail the
group runs like mad barely escaping with
their lives but goblin slayer has a
trick up his sleeve just as he spots a
goblin ship near them making priestess
girl whip up a magic light distracting
the goblins long enough until this swamp
dragon pops up and devours them whole
but the horrors aren't over yet because
goblin slayer knows that goblins don't
know how to use boats which means that
someone taught them this skill and if
the goblins were here long they would
have known about that swamp dragon and
wouldn't have dared using any boats
which means someone or something brought
all those goblins here recently and on
purpose the next day the group heads
back deep underground to find the leader
behind all of these goblins and this
time goblin slayer brings along his
newest pet a canary a bird designed to
panic at even the slightest hint of
poison gas being used within the area
because these goblins seem more than
intelligent enough to handle using such
deadly tools just then they cautiously
enter a room where they find something
horrifying a prisoner chained down and
unconscious but goblin slayer isn't
fooled and makes them realize that it's
a setup right before the door behind
them suddenly closes shut poison gas
then begins flowing out from within the
walls of the room having the group
cornered like rats goblin slayer then
hands the group a bit of charcoal and
tells them to wrap this in cloth and
around their face as this will protect
them from the poison within the air he
then demands that the group mix two bags
of quick lime and volcanic earth
together to form concrete and to block
the holes with but goblin slayer knows
that it won't be long before an army of
goblins comes crashing through those
doors and he's right because all of a
sudden a loud bang erupts just outside
and a horde of goblin beasts try barging
in through the door and the group
readies themselves for the most brutal
fight of their life but the news keeps
on getting worse because legolas chick
then hears the incoming footsteps of
something much larger in size than the
rest of the goblins just then the
biggest green beast you've ever seen in
your life rips right through the door
and it's piercing mandibles crave human
flesh it's a horrifying goblin champion
and the group prepares for the most
terrifying fight of their entire lives
okay this is insane this is a horrifying
beast it's a goblin champion a variant
of goblins considered to be a hero among
the goblin race and it's much larger
both in mass and equipment than regular
goblins now while they may be capable
fighters there is a way that this group
can take this goblin champion head on
and that will be to fight dirty this is
a battle between life and death and
playing nice isn't going to give us any
extra chances at winning here's how
we're going to do this we're going to
focus on two parts of the goblin
champions body parts namely the achilles
tendon and the popliteal fossa now in
basic anatomy the achilles tendon is
what pulls on the heel and allows us to
stand on our toes when walking running
or jumping however if an achilles tendon
were to rupture while the individual
would be still able to walk it would
greatly reduce that person's ability to
be mobile now while the physiology of a
goblin differs than that of humans the
way that gravity works on the goblin's
joints i think it's actually very
similar and it's a safe bet that if the
group focuses on slicing the area where
this goblin's achilles tendon would be
this would greatly limit its ability to
move secondly following the rupture of
where his achilles tendon would be i
would also slice this goblin's popliteal
fossa which is the area in the back of
the knee an area containing important
nerves and vessels passing from the
thigh to the leg like i said if we cut
the area where this goblin's popliteal
fossa would be even if he doesn't have
one i'm pretty sure that thanks to
gravity this goblin would feel the
sudden painful weight of his entire body
and that very large body would come
crashing down hard because we literally
just took out two very important parts
of his legs that you know he kinda needs
to stand on utilizing what we know of
basic anatomy this will allow us to at
least immobilize this goblin champion
and possibly get it on the floor this
way giving us the choice of either
running for our lives or taking this
goblin champion down the gang puts on a
courageous and desperate fight against
the goblins but it's no use cause this
goblin champion is too horrifyingly
awesome at what it does which is to kill
awarding goblin slayer with more than a
few bloodied bruises and sickening blows
to goblin slayer's face shocking
priestess girl into accidentally turning
off her magic force field letting all
the goblins in and allowing this goblin
champion to take a bite right out of her
sweet flesh but shockingly out of
nowhere goblin slayer surprisingly rises
up and jumps right on top of the goblin
champion pouring every ounce of his
remaining will into his final act
choking the [ __ ] out of the goblin
champion with some human hair eventually
killing him and sending the rest of the
goblins away scared shitless for their
lives thankfully priestess girl and
goblin slayer managed to barely make it
out alive the next day the gang then
goes to check on a now rested goblin
slayer before the group recovers from
the trauma of that battle and fill their
bellies with some food and get new
equipment and the gang prepares
themselves to go down again into those
horrifying sewers because this time
lizard guy tells the group that he's
found something within the sewers even
more menacing than a goblin champion and
something far more strange this creature
of chaos using its eye to unleash the
power of disintegration melting anything
that it looks at in mere seconds though
it won't attack unless provoked and
won't attack them unless they enter the
room ah okay this guy is a whole new
character and we don't know much about
it but what we do know is what it's
capable of aside from creating an
extremely hot beam of energy that can
disintegrate anything in its path it can
also dispel any active spells made
within its effective range meaning our
spells within its range will not work
however like we just found out it won't
attack us if we don't enter the room now
in this instance i think the best thing
we can do is to use some good
old-fashioned weaponry to take this
beast out since he'll be able to dispel
any spell we throw at him but in this
case i have to say what's the rush the
gang is acting like they're on the clock
when in reality there's no need to rush
at all no enemies are nearby as of yet
which is why i argue that this group
should take their sweet time in planning
out their next move i'd even use this
time to head back up to the town's
service to procure some explosives from
the town's armory draping a sock over
said explosive and attaching a fuse to
it now if we had trouble getting any
such views around town then we could
simply make our own by pouring 36 grams
of potassium nitrate along with 24 grams
of plain sugar into a cup and thereby
creating a 60 gram composition that is
then to be shaken up vigorously mixing
both particles together after which we
would add 1 3 cup of water into a medium
high heat frying pan quickly boiling the
water before adding the composition into
the mix as well and making sure to stir
the mixture until it dissolves
completely before adding a batch of 100
cotton yarn string into the pan making
sure to let this string soak up all the
composition thoroughly before laying it
out to dry on a pan sheet speeding this
process along by putting it in an oven
or whatever equivalent they have
available for about 20 minutes before
taking it out to cool for another 10.
now with the slow burning fuse that we
have in spades next we'd simply need to
form some axle grease or rubber solution
equivalent to whatever they have within
that town to seal the sock with they
could even seal it off with hot wax and
all of this is what will essentially
create a makeshift sticky bomb from here
i'd bring a whole carton of these bad
boys back down with me and simply camp
out and hurl these things at this
eyeball monster likely in quick
succession ideally sticking our
explosives onto its sweet face and then
going boom now if that doesn't work and
we need a distraction to keep its fiery
gaze from melting us as we throw our
bombs then one of us could simply run
around the eyeball monster in the other
direction while we throw our makeshift
bombs like a major league pro and voila
eyeball monster is taken care of you're
welcome the gang is at a loss for
tactics but goblin slayer has a trick up
his sleeve using legolas chick to
distract the monster's gaze dwarf guy
comes from behind to use a sleeping
spell on this horrifying eyeball monster
giving goblin slayer enough time to open
up a big bag of flour and throw it right
into the air right before lizard guy
summons a monster to head inside the
room realerting the now awakened eyeball
monster into unleashing his fire stare
until suddenly a massive explosion
erupts lighting the whole room ablaze
forcing priestess girl to shield off the
room for the group's protection after
the fireworks the gang counts their
blessings right before they realize what
this mirror really is it's a portal to
an army of goblins this is how they
arrived into the underground sewers of
the city but they don't have time to
react because just then legolas check
hears a swarm of goblins headed straight
for them and so the gang quickly sets up
a defensive position before they are
attacked by more horrifying goblins
including the same goblin champion back
from the dead this scares the [ __ ] out
of everybody lizard guy takes down the
mirror on the orders of goblin slayer
and the group takes cover under it
preparing for dwarf guy and priestess
girl's massive spell blast casting an
eruption across the entire underground
base destroying the mirror and killing
every last goblin with it later goblin
slayer confronts sword maiden herself
and finds out that she actually knew
about the goblins being underground the
whole time and she basically tells
goblinslayer that since she got violated
by goblins as a teenager she was too
traumatized to defeat them herself and
wanted the public to realize just how
awful goblins really are oh and she
totally has a hardcore crush on our boy
but he's too focused on goblins to give
a damn idiot the next day the gang gets
word that the demon lord in the capital
has been defeated however many of his
armies still remain active including
armies of goblins spread out across the
land that could show up at any minute
goblin's lair later in the day stumbles
upon the most horrifying thing something
that will shock everyone in this village
to their core hundreds of goblin
footprints just outside the village
goblin slayer then runs home back to
where he's been resting to tell this
chick that he's been checking up with in
a very pg sort of way to run because
these tracks of goblin footprints are
not like anything he's ever seen before
and it suggests that this army of
goblins definitely has a leader not a
shaman or a goblin champion but a goblin
lord and that the attack will come
tonight or tomorrow at dawn meaning any
outside help from the military won't be
able to come in time which means that
this village is all that stands in its
way and the village is entirely on its
own the goblin slayer then runs into the
town's center to warn all the
adventurers that goblins are about to
attack this village and that everybody
should join in on the fight and he begs
for their help unfortunately for him
though everybody thinks he's a bona fide
weirdo choosing to always be quiet and
stoic and to only take on goblin jobs
this is why they instead resist his
pleas for help opting to let him handle
this mess alone instead okay this is a
huge deal because if we thought ogres
and goblin champions were a big deal
enough then a goblin lord is beyond
terrifying because unlike other goblins
who are for the most part wild and
irrational beasts a goblin lord is the
only known rational goblin capable of
leadership and plotting unlike their
brethren they've evolved to be capable
of thought and high intelligence and is
a foe that we cannot take lightly they
are master tacticians expert swordsmen
and excel in leadership positions which
means if you take his skills combined
with the accelerated growth that goblins
naturally have this means that we have a
massive army of goblins headed by a
military genius more capable than most
humans are while goblin slayer spent
years training to fight goblins he
didn't spend time learning arguably one
of the most important skills that anyone
could learn in life which is social
skills being charismatic around people
can be vital too while some people don't
think that this will work however being
charismatic will draw people to you like
a magnet and make them more willing to
support you and your endeavors all
simply because they like you but right
now goblin slayer is looked up as a
non-sociable weirdo by everyone in this
room which means it were him we need to
quickly act fast in order to convince
these folks of our hiding debonair charm
because no one will want to help us
otherwise now while we can't fix other's
perceived impressions of us we can try
the act of humility and lessen ourselves
in front of everyone else because so far
everyone thinks that the reason we only
hunt goblins is that we think we're too
good for any other type of enemy and
they don't even believe that we deserve
to be civil ranked through goblins
laying alone which means the first thing
we need to correct is this perceived
image of ourselves by addressing it
head-on i would start by addressing and
revealing the reason as to why we've
only been hunting goblins all this while
telling the whole room of our traumatic
past involving goblins and the death of
our sister at the hands of a goblin when
we were a child i'm pretty darn certain
by showing a little bit of humility and
revealing the why as to how we came to
be that we will be able to gain the
sympathy of everyone here and ideally
gaining their respect or pity in order
to lend a helping hand now if this
didn't work then i would also talk to
the receptionist girl to see if she
would be able to create a makeshift
quest for us offering up a reward to all
those who decide to battle the army of
goblins because you've seen the way
she's been eyeing our goblin slayer
throughout the entire season we're
pretty darn sure that she will help him
suddenly this douchebag in red earrings
finally warms up to goblin slayers
please at the town center adventuring
guild also offers up a reward for the
goblins one gold for every goblin slain
and this definitely gets everyone else's
mouth salivating at that thought as the
whole faction of adventurers finally get
in on the action listening to goblin
slayer's plans of attack readying the
group for the most intense fight of
their lives the night arrives and the
goblins eerily sneak through the
grasslands in the distance leaving human
prisoners out in the open field firstly
to lure in the humans forcing the
adventurers to quickly rescue the
hostages right before the army of
goblins comes in charging in droves
erupting into a majestic battle of
attrition with blood spilled left and
right as man and goblin wrestle it out
with their lives on the line goblins
riding on wolves and the world's finest
top adventurers duking it out on the
plain grasslands and elven arrows
perforated the air in the thousands
causing more chaos to befall on this
town than anyone has ever experienced
before just then a bunch of goblin
champions come in running to test the
utmost strength of the guild's best
silver-ranked adventurers the surprising
amount of resistance and strength from
within the town starts to threaten the
goblin lord who way back in the distance
begins to retreat knowing that if he can
escape then the goblins will live
another day but too bad for him goblin
slayer already knows all of his moves
and he greets him head on ready to kill
him and goblin slayer walks up to the
goblin lord himself and the two engage
in close combat to the death the two
then charge at each other joust style
and swing blade for blade until our man
critically injures the goblin lord
pissing him off to the bone unleashing
something within him that comes charging
right back at goblin slayer slicing his
arm and knocking him down hard and the
goblin lord walks up to the slayer of
goblins the goblin lord begins stabbing
on our hero's face like a game of dance
dance revolution and he readies his axe
to kill the goblin slayer until his body
freezes up its priestess girl and she
casts a spell trapping the goblin lord
within a magical wall-like structure
trapping him good the goblin lord uses
his intelligence and cunningness to
articulate in plain english to please be
spared however this time priestess girl
isn't a pushover and lets goblin slayer
stab the goblin lord in the face and our
hero passes out but thankfully his balls
are bigger than those that watch our
anime channel i'm kidding and he manages
to get back up and head back to the town
center to a cheering group of
adventurers who dine and drink the night
away celebrating the town's safety and
the money that they've all just earned
they also celebrate the safe return of
the goblin slayer himself living yet
another day to take on a new adventure
involving goblins again and if you want
to join us on our next goblin don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
check out the how to playlist down below